pourquoi la mondialisation at-elle
accouché du terrorisme ça c'est la
grosse question
tout simplement parce que le monde
change à partir de 1989 avec la chute du
mur de berlin et l'ensemble de la preuve
de la planète va profiter de cette chute
du mur de berlin soit sur le plan
démocratique évidemment démocratie vont
apparaître notamment en europe de l'est
soit et où en plus d'un développement
économique ce sera le cas en europe de
l'est ce sera le cas en amérique latine
ce sera le cas aussi en asie où déjà les
dragons sont apparus ça sera le cas
également en afrique où on a des
démocraties et même des puissances
capable de jouer le jeu de la
mondialisation économique
il ya un endroit où c'est pas possible
c'est l'air arabo musulmane où il ya ni
démocratie ni développement économique
et c'est là en effet que des gens qui
vont contester cette mondialisation
pilotée par l'occident vont choisir le
terrorisme et notamment à travers al
quaida je rappelle que de 89 en 1991
halkin les fondateurs d'al qaïda ben
laden et zaouahri sont des gens qui sont
considérés comme des freedom fighters
des combattants de la liberté
et il choisit 191 la la la voie du
terrorisme après l'invasion du koweït
par les troupes de saddam et le fait que
des soldats coalisés d'origine
chrétienne soit venu ex que les troupes
de saddam hussein du koweit ils vont en
80 ans choisir la le terrorisme donc
l'expression violente ultra violente et
vont le faire non pas en déclarant que
c'est l'islam qui est menacée mais dans
le fond on déclare que c'est le mode de
vie arabo musulman qui est menacée et
l'économie aussi arabo musulmane qui est
menacée il reproche notamment le fait
que ce ne sont pas les arabes eux mêmes
qui exploitent les richesses du sous sol
mais que c'est des richesses qui sont
détournés par ce qu'il
nous considèrent comme être la tête du
serpent c'est à dire les occidentaux et
en particulier les américains donc on
voit en effet que la mondialisation qui
est une à rouleau compresseur qui va
bousculer l'ensemble des identités de
tous les peuples et bien dans le monde
arabo musulman comme ya pas de
développement économique comme il n'ya
pas de démocratie
ce qui va se révéler être vraiment le
refuge de l'identité et bien c'est le
livre sacré c'est coran et c'est le fait
que rien ni la mondialisation ni rien
d'autre ne bougera la moindre virgule de
ce livre sacré
[Musique]